birthday no birthday I know first
birthday I mean how was that great I'm
flying to New York right after I leave
here what a big party got a big part of
this weekend Saturday
I know cardia said she spoils her she
gives her everything she deserves
everything so how big is this party
gonna be is there a theme you just got
to see it's gonna be everywhere it's a
big big big big big party though you
know I'm sorry
it's our first child girl you know I'm
saying it's a big big celebration how
many gifts did you get her let's talk
about know you guys are big sports fans
anybody you were super stoked to meet
here tonight
I just got we just gave the awards of
Drew Brees man he's a great quarterback
even though we're from Atlanta and it's
a great rivalry between the Saints and
Atlanta Falcons but you know to my boy
Alvin Chimera he run the ball for him so
I feel like I felt good just having that
award to a great quarterback good record
breaker oh yeah what about you guys
let's talk about the new music you
hinted at it I know you guys met up some
individual projects would tell me about
what's going on with that and also
anything new for me goes we're dropping
a new project on the way control the
streets too and we we come in we come in
2020 topper 2020 just be on the lookout
for that Super Bowl going crazy right
not oh well is it strippable
yeah it was $500,000 thrown at a strip
club okay well speaking of strip club I
gotta ask you about the trailer for
hustlers
how proud of you your girl she's gonna
be in a movie movies big big big things
you know we're just gonna keep moving
keep on putting pressure on them keep
the pressure on them foot on the Knicks
you know I'm sad have you seen the full
trailer I seen it all
what do you think of it it's gonna be a
beautiful thing mm-hmm it's gonna be a
beautiful time she kills it I'm sure for
SOPA so I know she said you're her big
supporter she couldn't do any of it
without you yeah man you know I gotta be
the coach I gotta make sure I see the
vision
he's super dad to super dad I got that
can we ask you guys we just want to
celebrate the women's soccer team really
quick we're just asking everybody we're
celebrating them at the ESPYs we saw
Alice Morgan she snipped the teeth
what's your victory dance if you're one
of those women's scoring the goal to win
the World Cup what's the migos victory
you know Sam with the trophy in hand you
know saying we need the men to step it
up man
we challenging the man
[Music]